Les politiciens dans un grand projet technologique et sophistiqué ?
Oh, ça va être un désastre.
Pas nécessairement.
Il existe un précédent de service technologique
qui a été initié par les hommes politiques dans plusieurs pays
et a connu un très grand succès :
les loteries nationales.
Prenons comme exemple la Grande-Bretagne.
Notre gouvernement n'a pas conçu la loterie nationale,
il n'a pas financé la loterie nationale, il ne gère pas la loterie nationale.
Il a simplement adopté la Loi sur la Loterie Nationale et voici ce qui a suivi.
Cette loi définit comment doit marcher une loterie nationale.
Elle précise certains avantages
que l'état peut uniquement accorder aux opérateurs.
Et elle donne des obligations à ces opérateurs.
En termes de diffusion du jeu parmi la population,
ça a été un franc succès.
Mais supposons que notre objectif
soit d'apporter une nouvelle activité économique à la base de la pyramide.
Pourrions-nous utiliser le même modèle ?
Je crois que oui.
Alors, imaginez que les politiques indiquent une installation.
Appelons-les les marchés électroniques nationaux, NEM pour faire court.
Voyez-les comme des services publics réglementés.
Ils sont donc sur un pied d'égalité avec l'approvisionnement en eau ou le réseau routier.
Et c'est une série de marchés pour un commerce de bas niveau
qui peut être accompli par une personne ou une petite entreprise.
Et le gouvernement a certains avantages
qu'il peut accorder uniquement à ces marchés.
Il s'agit de dépenses publiques qui passent par ces marchés
d'acheter des services publics à un niveau local.
Il s'agit de connecter ces marchés
avec les voies officielles au plus haut niveau du pays.
Il s'agit d'inscrire le gouvernement en tant que promoteur de ces marchés.
Il s'agit de déréglementer certains secteurs
de sorte que la population locale puisse y pénétrer.
Ainsi, les trajets en taxi peuvent être un exemple.
Et il y a certaines obligations qui devraient accompagner ces avantages
attribués aux opérateurs,
et la principale est, bien sûr,
que les opérateurs payent pour tout,
y compris toutes les interfaces avec le secteur public.
Alors, imaginez que les opérateurs gagnent
un pourcentage de marge sur chaque opération.
Imaginez qu'il y ait une période de concession
fixée sur une quinzaine d'années
dans laquelle ils peuvent emporter tous ces bénéfices.
Et imaginez qu'on dise aux consortiums qui souhaitent participer,
que celui qui arrive avec le pourcentage de marge le plus bas sur chaque transaction
pour financer le tout
emporte l'affaire.
Ensuite le gouvernement sort du cadre.
C'est maintenant dans les mains du consortium.
Soit ils débloquent une quantité épouvantable d'opportunités économiques
et gagnent quelque chose dessus
ou tout s'effondre,
ce qui est dur pour les actionnaires.
Ça ne dérange pas nécessairement les contribuables.
Et il n'y aurait pas de limitations à d'autres marchés.
Donc, ce serait juste un choix de plus
parmi des millions de forum Internet.
Mais ça pourrait être très différent,
parce qu'avoir accès à ces installations soutenues par l'état
pourrait inciter ce consortium
à investir sérieusement dans le service.
Parce qu'ils devraient réaliser un grand nombre de ces petites transactions
pour commencer à avoir un retour.
Donc, nous parlons des secteurs tels que les coiffeurs à domicile,
la location de jouets, les travaux agricoles,
même la location de vêtements, les repas livrés à votre porte,
les services pour les touristes, les soins à domicile.
Ce serait un monde de petites transactions, mais très bien informé,
parce que les marchés numériques nationaux fourniront des données.
Voici une personne locale
qui doit potentiellement décider d'entrer ou pas dans le marché du babysitting.
Et ils pourraient savoir qu'ils doivent financer la sélection et la formation
s'ils veulent entrer dans le marché.
Ils auraient à faire des entretiens d'évaluation avec les parents locaux
qui veulent un groupe de baby-sitters.
En vaut-il la peine ?
Devraient-ils regarder d'autres secteurs ?
Devraient-ils se déplacer dans une autre partie du pays
qui manque de baby-sitters ?
Ce genre de données peut devenir la routine.
Et ces données peuvent être utilsées par les investisseurs.
Donc, s'il y a un problème de manque de baby-sitters dans certaines parties du pays
et le problème est que personne ne peut se permettre la sélection et la formation,
un investisseur peut payer
et le système remboursera les gains augmentés des individus
les deux années suivantes.
C'est un monde au capitalisme atomisé.
Ce sont des petits échanges de simples individus,
mais c'est très informé, sûr, pratique, avec peu de frais généraux et immédiat.
Des recherches approximatives suggèrent que cela pourrait débloquer
l'équivalent d'environ 100 millions de livres par jour en nouvelles activités économiques
dans un pays de la taille du Royaume-Uni.
Cela vous paraît-il improbable ?
C'est ce que beaucoup de gens disaient du turbo trading
dans les transactions financières il y a 20 ans.
Ne sous-estimez pas le pouvoir de transformation
des marchés vraiment modernes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)